this is Eureka Missouri a city that
floods repeatedly we're talking
catastrophic floods twice in less than
two years yet more rain and dangerous
flooding are affecting millions in parts
of the Midwest and South tonight across
the Merrimack River notorious for
flooding very quickly and others but
just 12 miles downstream is a town
called Valley perk it stayed pretty dry
thanks to a levee a giant artificial
embankment that surrounds the city
designed to keep water out Valley Park
got their levee largely because the city
was willing and able to pay for it it
kept their own town dry but here's what
flooding looked like in neighboring
towns including Eureka that didn't have
levees the valley park levee was stood
the water of that levee holding could be
part of the problem he suspected the
same levee that protected Valley Park
may have been to blame for devastating
flooding in Fenton Marika and Arnold can
a levee protect one town while making
flooding worse for others especially
towns that can't afford a levee a fluid
mechanics lab a 13 foot long model of a
river and some adorable tiny houses will
help us find out
people love levees there's about a
hundred thousand miles of these
embankments across the u.s. sometimes
concrete sometimes earthen for centuries
we've built them between humans and
rivers we even write songs about them
[Music]
but it turns out even when levees are
effective they can still be devastating
as far back as 1852 levees came with a
very important warning Charles Eliot jr.
a famed u.s. civil engineer caution that
levees confine rivers and caused them to
rise higher and slow faster and relying
on levees encourages of false security
but he was largely ignored levees became
the default for flood control mostly
funded and constructed by local entities
some Riverside communities that could
afford it built taller levees for more
protection while less fortunate
neighbors dealt with the devastating
effects to show you what we mean we went
to the banks of the Mississippi River to
a fluid mechanics lab where a team of
engineers from the University of
Minnesota built us this landscape model
to test flood scenarios
overhead a scanner collects 3d data to
measure exactly what's happening it's a
generic model of a river with no levees
that means when the water level
increases it overflows and spreads
across the floodplain often creating
important wetland habitats that's home
to a variety of species putting in
levees cuts rivers off from this land
destroying floodplains and wetlands it
allows people to convert these areas
into farmland or build houses on and
while levees protect these communities
from flooding they constrict the river
into a narrow channel making the water
flow faster and higher that creates a
bottleneck leading to additional
flooding upstream if all levees are the
same height both sides should be about
equally protected from the average flood
and if the river rises so much that the
water over tops the levee then both
sides should flood pretty equally but
let's say people on one side of the
river
lobby for higher levees now instead of
both sides flooding only one floods the
side with the lower levees is at a clear
disadvantage so what can people in flood
zones do we can't just pick up and move
major cities we need levees to protect
places like these there is an
alternative
we could build levees farther back so
rivers could still expand and create
wetlands these setback levee is ease
flooding on both sides rather than
protecting one city at the expense of
another
this approach is common in other parts
of the world like Holland for example
but not in the u.s. here we tend to
build levees right next to rivers some
communities that can afford to build
higher levies do so at the risk of
others with little oversight we do have
the Army Corps of Engineers a federal
agency tasked with regulating a fraction
of all levees
they have to ensure at least on paper
that federal levies won't dramatically
raise local flood levels but those
engineering predictions don't always
match reality for instance the Army
Corps designed Valley parks levy in the
early 90s with data and software from
that era Engineers estimated the levees
impact on neighboring areas would be
minimal but by the time it was completed
in 2005 the region had grown
significantly more people had built
alongside the river
increasing the risk of flooding which
wasn't considered in the original plan
while we don't know the precise impact
of Valley parks levy on neighboring
towns just yet since the levee was built
the region outside Valley Park has
suffered two of the worst floods in its
history the Army Corps says they've done
nothing wrong and that the levee meets
all state and federal laws but there's a
growing body of research that shows
levees push flooding onto surrounding
communities that have lower levees or no
levees at all researchers measured water
levels around 13 levees in the Midwest
and found they all increased flooding
some by over 5 feet as the climate
changes and cities push for higher
levees flooding is only expected to get
worse especially along the Mississippi
River which is almost entirely lined
with levees some of these embankments
have been substantially raised since
their completion against federal rules
making flooding worse across the river
and upstream so yeah we need some levees
but the system for regulating them is
broken even though the science
overwhelmingly shows that constructing
higher levees makes flooding worse in
the long term we keep building them
taller
passing our problems upstream
[Music]
laughing border great